قرب خطوط التماسي مع قوات النظام التقينا
بعائله ابو احمد يعملون بالمقاومه بعد
انحيل بينهم وبين مصدر رزقهم
سيطرت قوات النظام على قريتهم منذ اعوام
وبات الوصول الى مزارعهم في محيط القريه
محفوفا بالمخاطر منذ سنوات يكتفي ابو احمد
باطلاله على بستانه اذ لا يستطيع الوصول
اليه لجميع اصوله
نوصل لها بسبب القنص والمخاطره والضرب
يعني ما حد بس يجري يفوت لهون خالص خالص
في المناطق المنخفضه البعيده عن مرمى
نيران قناصه قوات النظام تجني عائله ابو
محمود بشكل طبيعي
ايه في مره دقائق وبدا القصف المدعي
اضطرابات الاجواء واختبات العائله تحت
الاشجار من طائرات الاستطلاع
ومع اشتداد القصف في وقت فرابه زاد خوف
العائله
لم يبرح ابو محمود مكانه املا بعوده
الهدوء وعوده عائلتي الى العمل من جديد
[تصفيق]
سوريا المرتبه الرابعه عالميا في انتاج
الزيتون قبل عام 2011 والذي قدر حينها
بمليون طن سنويا حسب وزاره الزراعه
وتراجعت الى المرتبه السادسه عالميا خلال
سنوات الحرب الماضيه
تاتي ادلب في المرتبه الثانيه بعد حلب في
انتاج الزيتون اكثر من 100,000 طن سنويا
يعاني اهلها اليوم صعوبات عده سواء عند
جنين المحاصيل او محاوله تسويقها مع توقف
التصدير
ايام من التعب والخوف يقضيها المزارعون
للحصول على كميات قليله من الزيت ربما يرى
البعض انها لا تساوي المخاطر التي يتعرضون
لها لكنها بالنسبه لهم تعني قوت اطفالهم
ومصدرهم الوحيد
امام الحسين